okay we will live a little bit day a go
and we'll see some gains from there from
the Big O which is actually I think
weaker than usual because they used to
have three sections and this year the
only f2 so the big group is a bit weaker
than usual still very strong job and we
taschek about 2700 today several other
players like 2650 orbit above walk to
another twenty young guy two of the top
players in the world
Zhou from China and on a method to which
is actually really having a very very
good tournament for her there so kind of
interesting in one American
representative Kaden 12 which is I think
he is - Tudor but actually today miracle
you know you should be thanking everyone
possible you know doesn't matter with
which religion for this game it was like
lost in the middle game lost after
middle game lost in the end game we will
maybe see that then gave me in a second
but this might be well quite for certain
will be the most important game of the
big group I mean Joe baba day I together
with Veritas check the only players 27
10 20 around that 25 and playing against
Grandmaster salad which is having great
tournament I mean okay obviously strong
Grandmaster but really having a great
tournament and gates : this game might
have decided the big group so after long
complications they got this position and
kind of look very simple
I mean very simple question well white
want to play g7 g8 take black holes and
win the game
so what can like do something all black
is kind of lost here I mean that's
really interesting because at first I
thought like it's lost yes but but this
is going to be this is going to be very
passive if you play this move something
like this if I remember okay check and
then and there will be ideas to take and
to come down with the rook it's going to
be very passive I think it's bad because
at some point white is going to take and
get his rook over there this actually
it's really interesting it goes back to
what we were discussing in the other
games and what we were discussing last
week I mean it's really unbelievable how
many games are in that world just this
tournament you know so Julian will look
at me and tell me
can't you see white is zero pieces
around the his King right Zillo pieces
so if black is only somewhat chance to
get something done here is against this
King so this move was played okay what
do we think about this move a for g7 was
played
so here it goes white is up a look for
two pawns but black succeeded in
creating some dents around around white
king many actually no defenses the pawn
that was there it's gone and the second
point is also you know disappearing soon
and white pieces are not coordinated you
know okay put a knight here and get the
rook summer to defend and okay white
might be able to consolidate and win the
game but with the night on g8 but the
knight is hanging yeah I mean it might
him yeah you will just take here I mean
now meaning it maybe also take here by
the way but
take but now it's probably just a draw
check and this move so what is is what
are blacks threats in this position
maybe this is the move that white
overlooked or maybe well maybe I just
didn't have much I mean which was Queen
e4 is one beautiful is a big threat I
mean actually this can be lost for white
I mean it can be dangerous maybe maybe
it is still at war but I mean okay this
is checkmate so we have to go here okay
this is minimum at all right because
this is checkmate I don't know if there
is more actually probably not still a
look is a lot but let's put computer for
a second do
okay so Queenie pho is a big threat so 9
f6 is impossible
okay look g3 was played illogical
getting the look out of being captured
and protecting b3 but take so now if Y
doesn't take the material is even pretty
much Bishop 2 points against this with
White King so weak forget about it so he
has to take and perpetual now I mean if
we want to study something practical
from that I mean probably none of us is
going to play in vacant say B but you
know in position that looks desperate
and this position looked really
desperate the way I see it I think the
way many people would have looked at it
finding some chances against mainly such
a lonely King is most straightforward
line you know just the king is so weak
see if you can go after it you know it's
like one leg has nothing to lose
secondly once again our amazing naked
King nothing around it that we want to
target there were two amazing games that
were played today in the section this
game this game we say I believe from 1:7
but Java lost yesterday again and savage
became the sole leader of the tournament
but Sarge made a door today with woman
with gran last her Messi took and Joe
bhava played quite amazing quite amazing
game I would I would say in the sense
that either it is completely genius game
or it is completely crazy game probably
a little bit of both so but definitely
played he played very
be very very mildly the opening like
okay okay Wow
yeah I mean yeah like just want to play
some sort of Kings Indian attack but
okay but that means that black is just
I'm going to be reasonably comfortable
okay a five not allowing before a foe
what what is the purpose of this move
just getting the C 4 square many times
right
the denied can go after some exchanges
and preventing black form expanding a
bit more I mean it's very typical when
we see a five we play a four so we can
control the C 4 square know B 5 it's a
very quite solid positional play
actually it is when you look at it it is
reversed which opening perfect exactly
just reversed Philidor exactly exactly
but black has to be totally okay maybe
okay plus like I think I think like it
slightly better here but I want to show
you where they plays in a start okay
Knight if one I mean so you look at this
position by move 12 when black has this
Center and all this development and
white has those pieces okay Knight will
go to g3 but
but wait what and see what happened here
okay Bishop g4 III think that could have
played a bit different but not really
important so first of all which move
should let be considering here
90 okay of course it's a move to
consider but what did Warbeck I'm not
certain I'm such a huge fan of this move
I mean maybe it's possible but I mean of
course it's possible but I think the
outpost on f5 is just incredible and the
you have opponent h6 so it's never going
to be easy to play g6 that's somewhat I
mean this f5 not so far away from
Nakamura game the 12th in line why it's
getting some play-doh I mean but
possible what c4 this what was played in
the game YYC for Julian so basically you
want to undermine white center right I
mean this idea c4 is extremely extremely
basic idea we actually feed many times
when when white plays c5 against some
lines in King's Indian he 5d 66 and
white plays this c5 right very logical
oh it's c4 so if take heel now I might
take and maybe now take maybe maybe wait
with this capture but all the pieces
seems active this way or another
maybe indeed take on g4 I mean clearly
the diagonal is open why took you I
thought this is normal I move but black
chose to take this way and now what
white I mean I have five possible I mean
maybe this one played like obsessed men
oh I said obsessed man yeah what what to
play here with black that's the right
approach now you have to be extremely
suspicious extremely careful but the
first thing is that okay
I take it always doesn't matter who your
point is doesn't matter you can be a
2700 Grandmaster actually is but you're
done no I just said it in general but in
actually haters so what happen if take I
can tell you know not making it a long
day so I mean okay maybe it's incredibly
insanely unbelievably deep but look d1
Queen d2 after work the one computer
wanna play this move and basically
attacking here and getting some
different know it looks scary but you
get compensated for it right you get a
price the price is a work right like for
example you know it's it's a decent
price maybe maybe not right i mean i
mean the camp is pretty much everything
has a price right Julian if I tell you
now to go outside and I don't know 10
with a just shirt for an hour you'll
tell me are you crazy right
but if I'll tell you okay I'll give you
$1,000 maybe you'll consider it now
now okay I mean seriously
now I have to do way more than that no
but that's the thing there are many so
but just is exactly the same do I
understand that black is extremely
extremely you know dangerous position
for black know of course but he got he
got paid for it he got paid a look to be
in that dangerous position remember I
said here many many times sacrifices are
basically an investment because not most
of sacrifices don't end up in a
checkmate so the big question is what
how much material your opponent is going
to give you back to basically fight
against your attack so if you sacrifice
the rook and your opponent can basically
neutralize your pressure for a big shot
you lost two pawns
if you gonna cost him more than a walk
you're winning
so basically when someone is sacrificing
very few percentage of the times it's
really checkmate most of the times is
basically saying hey giving your work
for you not to get checkmated gonna cost
you more than the hook that's what the
real what's happening is sacrifice so
you are suggesting Queen d2 wanna take
this pawn can I do
and what happened if I am going to play
smart move first I will need to find one
can i play here for example and I don't
know no Queen d2 I don't think is okay
huh it's actually no all right 22 was
second best move and 96 is best move now
your Queen d2 is number one move but
proudly mine IG six is Houdini's best to
applying like winning I I think I think
ninety eight after hook d1 is a
difficult to move
no but computers say winning no this you
know we are not going to play like those
players they are really really
really strong like you know I'm joking
around and okay now we are here to have
fun but they're really strong Pleasant
Joe Bobby is really genius player but
when your opponent sacrifice your
instinct should be okay
what happen if I take it doesn't matter
if you're a thousand level or s really
strong Grandmaster that's the way it
goes and white black believed white in
some way play Bishop here and white just
not scared of anything
history are there any other moves other
than history I mean I don't know yes he
like look to this seven but you mean
instead of Quincy one you wanna play
this move right I think this is what
bothering white he doesn't want to allow
the Queen to connect with the defense
over there
yeah amazing after Bishop c5 Luke d1
Queen c7 position is equal and Quincy
one is best best computable equal so
maybe you know some maybe they have seen
lines 20 moves deep I doubt it
you know III in purpose use the computer
here just to to see what's going on so
black and I am but I think he's already
a decent GM I mean ii ii ii won a big
tournament in december in netherland
gone again and he started actually
leading this tour and then is not
playing that amazing but is i think 18
so it's gonna is gonna be a decent plus
plus grandmaster but amazing just didn't
take and now is well got the same thing
basically it's under attack only with
what is up now not that impressive
played III okay so what what the balance
here okay what is the material balance
white seems to be okay right he has a
piece two pawns and still a lot of
pressure now a piece two pawns and still
a lot of pressure
take this pawn my instinct here white
wrong would not to be not to even get
close to that poll like if i were to
play a bullet game blitz game I would
play this move and I am swear to you I
have no idea what computer so maybe
we'll say this is resigning immediately
maybe we'll say it's mob but just the
instinct say hey this is dangerous
and you don't need any more noise from
the d-file
locate the eight best move equal but
it's just important you know like
seriously but one of the reasons why I
could come
those game with this game analyzed for
two hours and just tell you okay this
line this line this line I think it's
much like when I do commentary on ICC
it's much more interesting for me I hope
also for listen that we shall really the
ideas together without coming in all
analyzed yeah this is what I'm thinking
like now let me bring defenders let me
bring the look let me exchange this one
look how the game went Queen takes c4
okay
okay have fun you know like when you're
getting checkmated over there like let's
see Queen takes d4 Knight h5 - I have no
white is +1 + no bad bad bad instincts
for black phone black is pretty much
lost here Queenie 4 in 96 might have
been a better way here yes and I will
remember we mentioned we mentioned
somehow some versions of gospel gospel
of King h2 so there will be no checkmate
apparently Java heard it well what is
this idea maybe if something like this
I'm just maybe maybe this is what you
wanted to prevent yeah you can take here
but then the knight on h4 right and g2
so amazing move King H - amazing
but cuz Pavel had some against carp of
some some of the best attacking games
involved this move and actually believe
it or not this is the threat and if one
of you can find defense then should
definitely tell it to Houdini actually
Houdini says and he says King each to
second best move yes even a stronger
move he's saying by the way just for the
the dis move is winning the game
I guess this is this idea here in here
and then just getting to g7 with
checkmate ideas motoki we want to show
one more position so what to play here
lightly Bishop c8 but
it's amazing this one I mean this one
was even stronger it by the way it's
somewhat you know all white pieces that
are even not very far away from one
another
are in the attack I mean very rarely you
see the pieces like that and just this
is the threat to take on g6 black has no
check not even one check is helpless I
mean okay the game when not that far
away we know how to win yes take
Bravo so what happened black should have
taken the material it took on c4 which
was really bizarre like that porn you
know maybe I would not take also an
eight-six mom me a scary you know like
guru but then take on c4 doesn't make
sense and once again while the king the
king the king well we will give it one
to a defender and one of the maybe the
greatest well I think maybe the second
greatest Dutch player ever right
greatest was probably world champion max
Oliver but maybe the second one is young
demon debt actually play having a great
great tournament I think he's half a
point behind
sorry change abhava and I mean if he has
played chess at a high level I mean okay
let's say they are twenty five thirty
yeah he was top ten in the world before
they were born so that's not bad that's
that's not really bad like in the 80s
the early eighties it was at some point
I think number three in the rating list
played a match with Karpov but having a
decent tournament I want to go quickly
to critical position
okay I'm moving quite quickly and
alright so basically here we can we can
we can stop here a little bit it already
cleared that the character of the game
is quite quite determined black is has a
simple plane push push
win here create a passport to the pawn
on c3 white seems like he is quite
committed to an attack Queen h4 rook
will jump the knight is already here the
bishop is aiming all the way and this
knight can join and leg doesn't have so
many defenders it looks really scary
a5 Queen okay but diamond it played like
I said played World Championship match
played candy death matches when those
people you know and when these players
were either not born or in diapers
no depends when you wanna like he's not
easily gonna get checkmated I mean
that's actually really part of well one
is extremely strong but experienced also
like Bishop e7 already bringing one
defender f5 well the night might join
so strategically if black is surviving
the attack he's gonna win the game for
example just an instinct you know if I
look at this position if white will play
this move somehow my first instinct
would be to play what I don't know if
I'm right but my instinct what would it
be first move with black I'm thinking
here Knight to e4 like to actually not a
bad night relief for me between h5
right but the Queen will move I mean
you're not going it's not a check or
something you're not going to win
material may be 94 is a better I I
really don't know I can tell you that my
first instinct here huh 97 like this
night
okay this night beautiful but this night
prettier
well let's exchange them yeah III don't
let's see Bishop d6 okay no same idea
going after this one but let's see if
there is any tactical reason why he
doesn't like this it's just not
strongest you know st. Louis GM res you
know oh thank you okay yeah
no but just logical I mean all all black
has to do here is one thing you know
just don't get checkmated and and you
want the game
why do you just want the game and and in
order not to get checkmated you have to
do something amazing eliminate your
opponent attacking pieces I mean if I
take a piece that is somewhere else and
I change it for here so night bt7 will
be our first you know instincts are
important yeah Bishop d6 shot another
move I was thinking but I prefer to
bring something far away by the way
Knight e4 maybe not bad movie I mean
tiny bit dangerous maybe after Queen h5
yeah also not bad okay
so no this was amazing game so white
said huh maybe didn't say exactly that
but that's what he meant
so now I don't think that white want
that this movies a winning attempt but I
think he wants to make a draw because
after take is gonna take now if take
this is a door okay this is checkmate
and this is a door I was looking at this
today was it actually this is a serious
move
I I looked and talked if one is a door
which is a door but there's a winning
move here for white which is playing
this cool move only threatening
checkmate but not to h6 because after
take take so this is winning I mean
sometimes I want again not immediately
checkmate but winning the Queen pawns
everything and once again okay so what
do you do
94 and what now
big moment now big moment
okay I have to take here you you will
take right okay now I better find
something I better do it fast
Queen 286 I can play Queen to a six
maybe move the King King King goes to h8
now I think f6 and Knight f4 years to go
but this is insane maybe maybe maybe
have 6 & 9 fo let's see if there's
something stone okay just think of
sacrificing here Wow
if these days take okay yeah he wants to
go jump with the knife
I wonder by the way yeah is this move
yeah eliminating attacking immediately
because this and this this line I was
thinking is crazily dangerous and if
this is big mess then I just see this
for a second here here here yeah cutting
cutting the Queen from defense that's
too dangerous okay dude too crazy but
you know black didn't allow that I mean
this it's insanely complicated and
really what white is pretty much all in
but we can see that some moves like that
okay eliminate first of all a defender
we have to eliminate this and then
whether some sacrifice and f6 really
dangerous black doesn't have time here I
mean that can have a lot a lot of
material but he needs time he needs to
either eliminate defenders I saw the
attackers or get some defenders which
move can can you play - you
huh Queenie five no but okay but but but
for the right price I mean you know the
one you want to give me your queen okay
I'll take it and win the game not
Bishop at six you will run again into
same difficulty they think like some
something like that maybe
in that position okay
not many defenders around the king and
we're going to eliminate this efore
imported from the earth mr. Julian
not not even you know just you know
sometimes faces speak louder than
whatever I could say no but he restated
the importance of time that is crucial
here he's defending he'll keeping the
attack here if he thinks if black will
take here is going to be minimum two
pieces minimum because they will be
under attack the bishop and maybe also
the look so potentially C takes b2 has a
potential to win ten points of material
so if he can give two or three points
and just take the attack away it will be
over all that is important is really not
to get checkmated here because the
material will be enough so like better
to be up two or three points of material
in not checkmated in a queen up and
checkmated important know okay it was
insanely complicated but bottom line is
yeah this is only move because I mean
this is not so cool
but amazed but he's surviving here I
mean how many pieces are hanging here
amazing not fooling around
you eliminate those yeah no not fooling
around this like this is automatically
this night - annoying - attacking -
whatever go away that's it bye bye go
away so right now the material is equal
seven points each but okay this is shut
down and no attack yeah there are no
pieces around here no pieces I agree but
the only attacking piece is really the
Queen and it has no squirrels to attack
yes
yeah this is the state but you can take
the Queen agree this is one of the ideas
that you want to play you want to take
it right away
but the problem is that the bishop is
controlling the promotion square so
after you eliminate the bishop this is
your idea they work moved okay but the
game is still on because this is where
black pieces are but probably not
dangerous enough here comes one piece
yeah Black has one job now get as many
pieces as possible to cover squares over
dough and here another one doesn't
matter how far it is is controlling some
squares and he wants to bring the work
to defend the D file in some situation
okay there is no checkmate and the Lok
is defending so the game is finished the
work is blocking and that's it so this
is how not to get checkmated but it's
very easy an okay it's simple to say it
in one move get pieces don't get pieces
but why black didn't get checkmated I
mean you really figured out how danger
is positioning how dangerous it is any
immediately without any hesitation
eliminated the night gave back some
material brought the defenses and most
of the time extra material is actually
going to be the important factor